papi find X dot X Y dot good Y X dot x
and Y by integrating the acceleration
equations the acceleration equation is
taking the origin that's these heads
okay now they provide you the
acceleration equations but you can
probably think of what they are right
I've got to acceleration premiums one
corresponds to the horizontal and one
that corresponds to the medical right
and the reason why considering these
differently is better than this is
because we know what's going on this
what force horizontally is acting on the
Apple I mean I think about a force right
he throws it and then is anything
slowing it down or speeding it up and
the answer is no like I mean we're
simplifying things we're not thinking
about air resistance it's just going
it's not like um it's not like the Apple
is magically accelerating this way or
it's being pushed in the opposite
direction by gravity or something like
that X double dot what's happening to
the horizontal momentum it's not
changing okay so I'm gonna go after this
right away I can develop these equations
from here given these initial conditions
okay so um by the way I like to put in
the fact that when I go from one line to
another I actually say I'm integrating
down okay you're gonna have a lot of
equations flying around to try and make
the connections between them clear
alright you integrate up once with
respect to time so from zero you get a
constant the first one of many right
you're gonna get more so there you go
introduced it okay but when T equals
zero right and initial conditions you've
got this it's great a fire right in fact
because you've got no acceleration
horizontally
you've always got this don't you that is
always going to be the horizontal Wassa
T so you can say therefore the velocity
will be the square root of five all the
time no exceptions
okay we want the X equation is our
displacement for horizontal so we
integrate again
see X where engineering with a check to
time so what do you get square root of
five t plus another constant okay okay I
know in situations like this where you
start at the origin you've got no forces
acting on it it is very simple but you
can't leave out these constants
important okay now what
good because I begin at the origin this
constants going to evaluate to zero so
therefore now I have my displacement
equation for the horizontal axis great
I'm gonna rehearse exactly the same
thing but for verticals okay now again
I'm thinking about what forces are after
your miss a pool what's accelerating it
up or down okay what's in the situation
this is gravity that's that's the thing
that pulls it back down to the ground
and there's nothing else okay
now it either be minus 9.8 or minus 10
in this question they going with ten
okay there you go
so we climb up the ladder once
integrating to get to Y dot and what do
we get negative ten T plus Oh another
one okay
initial velocity in the upward downward
direction
is this guy right so when T equals zero
this sh appear to five right okay so I'm
getting Y dot equals negative 10 T plus
2 root 5 ok and as you can see as T gets
bigger right this stays where it is but
this will get this number you will get
increasingly negative eventually it'll
take over and that's why it comes back
down okay
okay we can integrate again and this
will give us vertical displacement okay
what happens
minus 10 T negative 5t squared plus 2 5t
plus the fourth and last constant array
we got there I mean of course we got
four consoles because we had to
integrate four times right okay again
we're starting at the origin which is
zero zero so thankfully he becomes zero
they got four equations right